[Music]
jason's in boston hi jason welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken how are you folks better
than we deserve sir how can we help
thank you um so my wife um she just
downloaded the app she's actually
listening at home so you're in a sense
talking to both of us at the same time
which is good cool um
so we um we just decided that we are
going to uh start the baby steps um and
with some unfortunate mishaps we've uh
we've fallen behind in some of our bills
and uh we don't have a 1 000 emergency
fund yet um so
where do we start what do we do wow
so what happened
uh well so my wife is a breast cancer
survivor um
and uh
and our oldest son who helps contribute
to the house just lost his job and um
and my hours were cut just a little bit
so we we've got a
just uh just a big financial mess and
mix that in with some poor spending
habits and
here we are yeah okay
well um there's
certainly we're going to put you guys
into financial peace university to help
you turn this around showing you how to
handle money and how to do a budget and
everything but it sounds to me like at
the core you've got a uh an income
crisis
more than anything i'll let ken address
that in just a second as far as the baby
steps go
your first goal before you start the
baby steps is get current
that may mean selling stuff it may mean
having a garage sale it may mean taking
extra jobs 16 of them
uh it may mean selling so much stuff the
kids think they're next
uh that kind of thing okay so i'm
talking radical because you got to get
current fast
because this is such a tenuous
scary place to live your wife dealing
with medical problems and now dealing
with we can't even stay current on the
light bill it she it's terrorizing her
and i want i want you guys all
to get
i i i but
i don't need it but i'm saying for your
sake i've been where you are not on the
cancer part but on the broke part and it
just scares the crap out of you and to
get away from that level of terror and
fear is your first
order of business so getting current on
a budget
is first then start the baby steps and
doing anything you can in the short term
to get your income up and then the long
term to get your income up is next ken
yeah jason curious what do you do for a
living now
i i work for uh fedex okay and so d when
you say you had your hours cut how much
uh so they they cut me down like like a
day or two over the last uh
over the last couple of weeks
but that's going to be getting back up
as we as we continue towards the the end
of the summer here what are you making
over the course of a year last couple
years what do you make
uh i'm right around 70
between 70 and 75 000. yeah what are you
doing driving or loading
uh driving yeah okay what's the long
term for you have you thought about it
what would it look like up the ladder a
couple rungs doing what kind of work
um i actually enjoy what i'm doing um
and you know i
yeah what are you going to do on these
off days to create extra income then
that's more than you're making now
uh so in the even right now i'm i'm door
dashing and driving for lyft okay
good good
yeah i think that's good i would
challenge you though because of your uh
ability and what you've done with fedex
that's a nice little credible brand
there i think i'd be looking for better
delivery jobs uh for at least six months
even if you're packing in some crazy
hours maybe driving for one of the large
soda companies they tend to have they
have better hourly rates instead of you
doing door dash and i think you can make
more money in driving
uh
you can get some part-time jobs because
right now in the delivery game period
like so take all the trucking companies
you might even be able to drive a
smaller sized truck they are desperate
right now we've got a big shortage of
workers dave in the supply chain world
so if you like driving i'd kick the
tires is what i'm saying jason you might
not be able to intended yeah there it is
i stepped right into it uh but i do
think you can make more money driving
than doordash and uber or lyft yeah i
mean you've got a cdl probably and so
yeah you could probably step into some
local delivery stuff
uh you know some short-term 18-wheeler
stuff or whatever be north of 20-25 an
hour versus lyft and that's my point he
can make more buck for his for his time
and anything uh i i just i want you
working so many hours that your
teenager's not in the mix
for carrying the family weight
uh that uh because you you are going to
make so much more than he is yeah
unless he's unless he's doing an app
that makes two million dollars a year or
something but short of that you're gonna
you're gonna outperform out earn your
teenager and you should
uh so yeah and as much as your wife's
health allows um uh same thing because
here's the deal
ten thousand dollars extra over the next
two months
changes your life
not only do you get current you put a
thousand dollars in the bank and you
start working your way out of debt
i mean your ten thousand dollars away
from a lot of peace
a lot more peace than you have today and
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go get
a lot of work and get ten thousand
dollars how fast can i gather up ten
thousand bucks i'm making that number up
i don't know how far behind he is but i
mean that's probably going to cover it
well i think it's a good example dave
because i think there's a lot of people
listening watching i want to encourage
you right now dave's not just throwing
this motivational speech out ten
thousand dollars is very doable in
today's economy we are looking at right
now a 3.6 unemployment rate what does
that mean to you out there who need
extra money to get that shovel bigger to
get out of debt or in this case just to
get started it actually means looking
out there and seeing there is such high
demand and you take this area the boston
massachusetts area big metropolitan area
you would be surprised how desperate
employers are to get somebody they can
count on and the money is way better
than it has ever been it's a white hot
opportunity for part-time income yeah
for 20 to 20 to 30 an hour stuff yes sir
absolutely never agreed that that
pre-covered you would have never been
made ten dollars do it yeah not even
close yeah and that's um you know that
that's that's real
real well give you an idea take walmart
national company okay just so you all
have some real numbers here they're
starting warehouse workers or people
that are stocking shelves and off hours
if you want to hustle and get after it
you can be in the 20 to 25 an hour just
doing that kind of work yes you're
exhausted and you're tired but again
what would it take to get to ten
thousand in two months i'm trying to get
current that's right get my get my back
away from the wall get the wolf away
from the door i want to put a i want to
put a bullet between the wolf's eyes i
want him to go away
and uh the wolf at the door is a it's a
scary thing man i mean i've had my
lights cut off my water cut off it's
with little babies in the house that's
what happened to us when we went broke
30 years ago and it scares you at places
you didn't know you had
and it makes you i mean
you stand in the shower and cry because
you don't know what to do you're so
overwhelmed
and you don't have to boil the ocean
here you just got to go get some quick
money any way that's moral and legal
fast go get you some money fast and then
you can back down and reassess your
overall career goals that's correct and
other stuff and start to maximize your
time and think where do i want to be in
10 years do i still want to be doing
this in 10 years is this company stable
are they going to continue at this level
you can ask all those questions but
right now go get some money it's a great
point you can't make good long-term
decisions when your head's on fire
because of the financial stress get
short-term stability excuse me
short-term stability and then we start
to plan
financial wellness and growing building
wealth like our live events we're doing
so hang up
hang on and austin will pick up and we
will get you a copy of or we'll get you
signed up for a one-year membership to
financial peace
university and that'll plug you into
every dollar the budgeting app and you
and your wife commit to doing those
lessons together there's nine
videos almost 10 million people have
been through this course and if you will
do what we teach you to do in there
while you go get some money
it'll change your whole life
and uh and and then you can call up and
tell the lie and say dave you changed my
life because i won't have changed your
life you will have changed it you're
going to go get this but you're in a
perfect place
because jason because you're in that i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
place
i i i hit bottom man i said never again
never
never
again
when you say that when you yell that at
the mirror
that's when you're ready to change your
life
this is not an intellectual discussion
this is a transformational event
intellect doesn't cause transformation
emotion
does viscerally down inside howling at
the moon never
again
will my family be in this place
when you say that then never again your
family will be in this place because
you're going to go do what it takes to
get her done baby
and you're that kind of guy that's why
we're going to give it to you and you
call us back and tell us how it's going